Walter what died meters on Sheila's okay
okay no you don't you don't need to do
that this isn't a session what do you
need I explain you what happened with
Schreyer it was mostly netball I took
the van
I drove us out there you did yes so what
you didn't believe me I believe that you
care about your friend and I understand
that so where is he what did they take
him nobody took him anywhere he's back
but you don't have to do that okay you
can tell me the truth that is the truth
ire needed more help than we can give
him here and he's with his family
they'll decide why why because the way
he thought was going on huh what did he
think was going on if I tell you you're
gonna have me moved and thought all my
stuff - of course not I just saw them
they're throwing out all of a [ __ ]
they're not throwing it out look we both
broke the rules okay whatever's
happening with Schreyer is also
understand what I'm thinking sometimes
we all think things that make us
uncomfortable everyone and I'm different
because wife because you want to be here
that's it
well in my experience it makes a very
big difference yes sometimes people that
need the most
I've been trashed his [ __ ] harmonica
I mean why can he take that with him
wherever he was going you're worried
about him aren't you yes I am
I haven't do the fish ah I got rid of
them just figured it was for the best I
can get into it you were employed at the
homecoming transitional support center
how do you feel happy what we're seeking
here is information nation what were
your duties there I don't know you don't
know I know why I'm here I want to be in
compliance with all this compliance have
you ever forgotten something something
big
you think she's a place or they want to
help us out we're here to help them
we can leave whatever we want this is
about your future you should think very
carefully
I could take care of them if you want
look what did she know you're worried
aren't you
yes I am
you